and minimalists hello simpletons I'm
Joshua fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists you know Ryan's spring
cleaning is right around the corner but
we need some wait until spring we
needn't even wait till tomorrow to
declutter our homes and today we're sort
of getting back to the basics so this is
just you and me in the studio we're
gonna talk about decluttering we're
gonna talk about organizing and we're
gonna talk about letting go of excess
stuff we've got a lot of questions today
so let's jump right in the first one is
from John in Oakland I had a question
about my parents kind of go into Mormon
minimalize I have done so myself
luckily I just had a big move right
about the time I was thinking about
sentimentality and getting rid of my old
positions it was great and I was talk to
my parents about it
I thought my dad is very much a a
just-in-case guy that is really a very
like at his core you know he's a big
goes and buys you know Christmas lights
the day after Christmas so he can have
them you know he could spend a little
less money on it overall and then he
like I got sees himself like a little
bit like a Santa Claus I guess you know
anytime anybody has any problems or or
they have a question you know and
they're over our house he could you can
walk him down to the basement but I
think this might help and it does and
and it feels great I don't know how much
it happens to her anymore but I know
that that is a big part of kind of how
he sees identity in like the
neighborhood stuff so I was wondering
you know when you say that what's the
worst that could happen to get rid of
this stuff right well you know the one
hitter is like well well you know he
won't have a bunch of stuff in his
basement where like he can go and get
stuff but really like I said he does tie
up a lot of his identity
you know he's 70 years old I don't know
I don't know if I could give it tips
into the middle aspect because of the
way of life and yeah I'd give him
philosophy because you know he's just I
think he might just be happy with kind
of where he is or you know and doesn't
you super happy but I think he doesn't
doesn't want to put any effort to change
this really highlights something I
wanted to talk about today Ryan and it's
that I don't think minimalism is
necessarily for everyone sure and I
think it's important it's important to
to bring that to the forefront early on
to me minimalism worked really well for
me simplifying my life worked really
well for me because I was discontented
by the status quo when I when I say
status quo I mean I was
contented by the amount of things I
owned by the constantly pursuing the
purchasing of new items the acquisition
of items the taking care of items the
storing of items having the bigger house
for all the items all of those things
were stressing me out
and so we have a couple questions within
John's question here within his
statement really that I'd like to unpack
first off I'd like to say if your father
is contented with his stuff then please
don't try to force minimalism yeah
that's one thing that stood out to me he
said I don't know if I could convince
him to be a minimalist and I don't think
you and I are trying to convince anyone
of anything no I mean we are you know
we're sharing our recipe we're sharing
our story and if people connect with it
great right but if they don't that's
okay too
totally agree yeah and and so if your
father is reaching out asking for help
that's one thing if he is contented with
the things that he's doing he's buying
these Christmas lights right after
Christmas which by the way is the best
time to buy Christmas lights if you're
trying to save some money yeah and you
know you're gonna use Christmas lights
the following season right yeah and so
if he has just a basement full of stuff
that he that is adding some sort of
value to his life please don't try to
convert him don't go out and proselytize
and then the second thing that I want to
talk about here is if you are trying to
help someone simplify their lives
instead of telling them what they should
do the best thing to do is be that
example for them show them how you've
experienced benefits from simplifying
your life and then how that might
translate for them of course the
benefits are different for each of us so
you letting go of your Christmas lights
in your basement John might bring you
great joy for him it might actually make
him discontented and so you brought up
the question what's the worst thing that
could happen these are two questions
that you and I Orien we often ask
ourselves what's the best thing that
could happen and what's the worst thing
that can happen yeah we often start with
though what's the worst thing that could
happen and I think that's that's an
important question because some of these
things nothing Bad's really gonna happen
you get rid of the Christmas lights in
your basement what's the worst thing
that can happen I don't know maybe you
have to buy more Christmas lights in the
future maybe not
nothing terrible's going to happen there
but sometimes there are good answers to
that question like if you're gonna go
skydiving what's the worst thing that
can happen well your parachute doesn't
open that's the worst thing that could
happen and so you have to be extra
cautious with that and so there are some
fears that are warranted some fears that
are not but on the other side what's the
best thing that could happen if you
simplify your life well you make more
time for your health your relationships
your community your creativity these are
all giant upsides
from letting go of your stuff however
your dad John he may not he may not
experience those those same benefits
that you're experiencing now he brought
up one other thing Ryan the the just in
case items his dad's holding on to all
of these items just in case now you and
I have two different rules we have a
just-in-case rule we have a just for win
rule by the way if you're listening to
this at home you can actually download a
free ebook that we have it's called
sixteen rules for living with less it's
the minimalist rulebook and both of
those rules are in there as well as 14
other rules it's a free ebook over on
our website the minimalists calm
/resources and in there we try to
differentiate between the justin case
items which you and i argue you can
replace those things for less than
twenty dollars in less than 20 minutes
from wherever you are but there are some
items that are just for win items and i
would even argue that these christmas
lights if he knows they're gonna use
he's gonna use them every year holding
on to them actually makes sense because
it is a just for win item he's certain
he's going to use it the just in case
items are like I don't know maybe maybe
I'll use this someday I'm not sure and
so I give myself permission to let go of
any of those just in case items which
I've let go of tens of thousands of just
in case items yeah
but I do hold on to some just for win
items I know that I'm going to use them
at some point and there's some other
rules that are applicable within that
same rule book as well the 9090 rule
works really well for me although it
wouldn't it works 99% of the time it
wouldn't work for Christmas lights right
it's nice about that rule book man is
that you know John's dad he can he can
manipulate those rules whatever works
best for him
so the 9090 rule you're right that might
not work that's not going to work
Christmas lights even the just-in-case
rules because like I will I will hold on
let's say I get I don't know dude last
thing you think of was like an Ethernet
cable that came with a modem or
something when Mariah and I moved into
our apartment that Ethernet cable
already had one and I was like oh you
know what I actually might use this to
plug the you know router directly into
my computer or whatever else like I I
was like I might actually use this so I
held on to it just in case I didn't use
it for a few months and then I let it go
right so you know even those just in
case items you can still create
boundaries around those to where John's
dad doesn't have to get rid of every
single item that he has in his basement
you know you talk about those two
questions you know what's the worst
thing that can happen what's the best
thing that can happen some other
important questions are what will we
always tell people to ask themselves
when they're on their minimal a journey
is you know how might your life be
better with less and I was thinking as I
was thinking about John's dad I thought
maybe another way to phrase this John
can phrases to his dad is how might your
life be better if you lived more
intentionally and I'm sure that he has a
basement full of stuff and there's
probably some things down there that
maybe are stressing him out and those
are the things that John wants to help
his dad with where is his dad feeling
this angst and if you can help your dad
out with those those the sources of
ank's like that's going to benefit your
dad having him get rid of everything is
not going to make him happy he talked
about his identity that stood out to me
two men like his dad his identity is
helping people out and having things
that he can give other people reminds me
of someone at our event who was talking
about their library like I just love my
books I don't have to smell of them you
know I know I love I love how I turned
the pages friends come over and my
favorite part about owning my books is I
get to lend friends books and then they
go read them and then they bring them
back and then we have a nice
conversation around the books and that's
great like their identity is wrapped up
in meaningful conversations around the
books that they own that's that's not
the end of the world I mean I think the
identity thing can get a little bit
dangerous sure but you know really what
John's dad is a helper and that's what
his dad wants to do so John the question
isn't how can you get your dad to be a
minimalist the question is how can you
your dad be the best helper he can
possibly be
I love that man and by the way forcing
him to get rid of everything in his
basement would actually makes him more
anxious so so you're thinking about that
as well you're asking some really
important questions here Ryan and John I
would love to bring you and your dad to
one of our events I know you're in
Oakland we're getting ready to go on the
LES Coast tour we're gonna be talking
about minimalism and creativity less
side ribs talk about minimalism and
creativity and it sounds to me like your
dad is actually he's he is a very
creative person and he uses a lot of the
these things in his basement and
elsewhere in his house for a little
creative projects and and to creatively
help other people to contribute to the
people around him so if you want to come
to one of our stops I think the San
Francisco stop is the the closest one to
you we're gonna be talking about
minimalism and creativity we're gonna
have a special musical guest and a
special podcast guest in every single
city there's eight cities in total all
along the west coast of the United
States and Canada you can find your
tickets at the minimalists com slash
tour you can also sign up for our email
list to get notified when we're coming
to a city near you who do we got in San
Francisco Matt Nathanson yeah Matt
Nathanson yeah not only playing the
music I'm talk about creativity yeah he
is one of the most creative people I
know he's gonna play the music opening
up he's probably my favorite podcast
guest of all time yeah I mean what a
phenomenal conversation we had with him
and now we're gonna have him live at the
San Francisco event if you can't attend
those events we will have those recorded
for our folks on patreon as well our
next question is from Virginia in
Chicago I am totally over cluttered in
fear becoming a hoarder if I'm not
already a hoarder the reason is I have
had a lot of family members die and I
seem to be the depository for
everybody's stuff to the point of yes
Grey Gardens almost so if you all have
any ideas in addition to the 30-day
challenge and me hiring a declutter er
unless hear from you a few lessons here
Ryan before we get into Virginia's
question first off
there is a lot of emotion tied into our
things quite often sure and you can even
hear that in her voice there's quite a
bit of emotion here so I want to talk
talk about that for a moment because
your feelings are not the facts but they
in the moment they definitely feel like
the facts they feel like what is true
right and so for me one of the things I
noticed when I was dealing with my mom's
stuff is I was attached to everything
the average American household has
300,000 items in it when my mother
passed it was my first foray into
simplifying I didn't even know about the
term minimalism at the time but I knew I
had to do something with her stuff it
was my first inclination to rent a
storage locker a giant truck and just
put all of her things in storage and
perpetuity and just just in case right I
was holding on to all of these these
sort of memories right and the reason I
was doing that is when I went down to
Florida to address her items
I felt I felt overwhelmed by emotion all
of these memories that are in my mom's
things and and I it's funny my former
spouse just last week sent me an
envelope of some of my mom's stuff that
she found her parents basement know and
I haven't opened the envelope yet and
why is that because there's a moment
where I'm like okay emotionally I know
this is going to this is going to bring
up some good memories bad memories
whatever but it's going to bring forward
a lot of emotions that aren't
necessarily facts and so I need to be in
the right space to deal with it now that
doesn't mean putting something off
forever but it means you don't as these
things are thrust upon you it may not
always be the the best and most
appropriate time to deal with them
immediately yeah but before it even gets
to that I think here's a word of warning
to all the parents and grandparents out
there and I'm a parent so I'm already
started to think about this yellow is
only six years old but I don't want to
leave her 300,000 items that she has to
deal with yeah I don't want to burden
her but quite often we don't understand
we're saving these things because we
think oh my kids or my grandkids are
gonna want these but maybe we had to
think about a different way oh no my
kids and I
grandkids and my family they're gonna
have to deal with this
am i burdening my family by clutching
and holding on to everything and why
wait until I'm dead to pass those on if
they would get value from those things
when I die why not pass them on now if
they're actually going to get value from
them so if I have a great baseball card
collection and I'm just holding on to
for a grandson why not give it to that
grandson right now because he could
enjoy it now and not wait 20 years or
however long yeah and also if they don't
want that baseball card collection they
get to make that decision yeah and let's
say they refuse to take it you have
permission to let that go right then the
only reason you're holding on to it at
that point is it's for yourself it's not
for them anymore
I like what you're talking about Josh
because she has two really good ideas
the 30-day minimalism game and hiring a
professional organizer which when I
think about hiring a professional
organizer what I think about is bringing
someone into your life to help hold you
accountable that's a great point and
sometimes you know a professional
organizer can be just a good third party
who can be honest and open with you and
they're free of the judgment of your
personal life it's like you know I will
go see a therapist sometimes because I
need a third party to unpack my thoughts
with someone who is you know not biased
right it's not like you're sitting out a
podcast Sean who has his own biases and
wants to make sure he doesn't offend you
or whatever but sometimes I do unload my
problems on podcast Sean well yeah I do
too we do it we do it every Tuesday
actually that's right now Ryan well I
mean where I'm going with this though is
that those are two really good ideas but
to initiate those good ideas she has to
have emotional leverage to do that and
what you just went through talking about
you know why am I gonna hold on to this
stuff I don't want to burn my children
everything you just went through that is
a very good way to get emotional
leverage and for me like that's what I
think Virginia needs to start is with
getting to the root of why and you know
do we have a magic bullet answer like
okay well here's a third option
can do I mean you could do a packing
party with one of your rooms or maybe
you just do it with a drawer or a closet
but ultimately once she gains that
emotional leverage there's gonna be a
lot of work that has to be done and I
think that's really what Virginia's
scared of yeah yeah and I think we're
scared of it because it seems so
overwhelming in the moment because
anytime there's a major task it's the
reason we procrastinate is the thing
seems much bigger than it actually is
and but when you chunk it down to
something smaller
it's the reason the 30-day she mentioned
the 30-day minimalism game which by the
way you if you want some help with that
go to the minimalists comm slash game
all the details are there it's a free
game it's just you can actually download
a free calendar now so we have a
principle calendar that people can print
out and sort of go through the game
together it's it's a free count which is
really cool too man is like there's a
whole community online around this
30-day challenge right so it's another
option for her to get some
accountability partners right and some
support as well yep because right now it
seems like what you're missing is the
support so so it could be a professional
organizer which by the way Sean let's
put a link to our friends over at nay PO
the National Association of Professional
organizers in fact I think they changed
that acronym but we've given talks at at
their conference before and these people
you Ryan you and I will often say that
organizing is often well planned
hoarding right is usually well planned
hoarding organizers actually get this
professional organizers realize the best
way to organize your stuff is to get rid
of most of it tweet that podcast shot
now realizing that is we're not talking
about getting rid of everything and
we're also not talking about keeping
everything and just putting it in an
organized system of container store bins
what we're talking about is all of these
things Virginia have been thrust upon
you have family members who have died
which by the way it's now those things
have been thrust upon you first off you
don't have to necessarily accept
anything you don't want to accept I just
want to be clear about that right now
you're not forced to deal with these
things you get to choose whether or not
you
want to deal with these things but if
they're already in your house now yes
you have to do something about them now
is a good time to to start the process
but start by chunking it in some way by
doing the 30-day minimalism game by
setting up some rules for yourself we
already talked about the the minimalist
rulebook and by having some outside
counsel that doesn't have to be hiring a
professional organizer it could be some
friends and family you can do it when
you and I did your packing party the
reason we did that was support and
accountability right instead of you
having to go through your whole house on
your own it was packing everything up
pretending as if you were moving and
actually making it into something that
is an emotional process making it
something that's fun and when something
becomes fun when it becomes enjoyable
when there's actually joy there it
starts to remove the anxiety from the
process it removes the negative emotions
from the process and I'm not saying the
process doesn't have isn't gonna be
emotional but it can be the good
emotions that you experience by letting
go of all of this excess stuff Virginia
I'm gonna send you a copy of our book
everything that remains Ryan and I we
had this five year journey of
simplifying our lives you certainly
don't need to take five years to do it
in fact my my simplification took about
eight months for me it's a crime 21 days
and I still feel like I'm on my journey
though yes yes we reach that horizon but
there's a new horizon out there but in
everything that remains I wrote about
dealing with my mother's stuff so my
mother passed away and I had to confront
all of her items and I wrote about it
and everything that remains if you enjoy
our podcast I think you'll really enjoy
the audiobook version of everything that
remains it's my favorite thing that
we've ever written or if you want the
book book or the eBook version we'll be
happy to send those to you as well all
right Ryan what time is it it's time for
our lightning round where we answer your
text messages text your questions or
comments to nine thirty seven two zero
two four six five four those text
messages they go straight to both of our
phones we can't answer every question
but we'll reply to as many as we can
yes indeed there are the lightning round
this is where Ryan and I each do our
best to answer every question
just a short shareable lesson 140
character response we also put the text
to these minimal Maxim's in the show
notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you
like and now you can find all of our
minimal Maxim's in one place
minimal Maxim's com alright our question
is from Marie how can I have memories
and memory boxes and still be a clutter
free minimalist I mean so so we need to
parse out these two things right and
unfortunately we conflate memories with
our memory boxes quite literal yeah we
have boxes and bins and crates and and
storage lockers and containers and bread
boxes and old cookie jars and all of
these things that clutter every bit of
our homes they there in the Attic there
in the the guest bedroom storage closet
they all of these places that we just
store these things why because we say
well I want to keep my memories in there
but how often do we actually access
those things yeah we can access the
memories without accessing the things
and so my pithy answer for you is an
oldie but a goodie our memories are not
in our things our memories are inside us
yeah I think once we realize that that I
can let go of something and still retain
the memory that I have of the thing or
of the experience that I experience with
the thing it gives me permission to let
go now what I will say is also sometimes
our things can trigger the memories
inside us so before I let go of some of
my things what I'll do is I'll take a
I'll snap a photo of it and having that
photo still gives me the trigger to the
memory without having to hold on to the
the giant you sideboard cabinet or
whatever I just realized like thinking
about this question we are we're scared
of being forgotten but like what's worse
than being forgotten is forgetting our
own lives and I think that is why we
know that's why I
used to have the memory boxes it was I
wanted to remember every little detail
of my life that I could but yeah when I
went through those memory boxes like
during my packing party I realized that
hey maybe these aren't memories I want
to sit here and cling to ya and be they
really weren't that awesome of a memory
anyway and see you can create new and
should be creating memories see better
memories with the experiences were have
because Ryan you bring up a really great
point if we're always clinging to the
memories of the past we're not making
room for the memories we're creating
right now
you know something pithy there Shaunie
Oh make it real nice and post I've got a
couple pithy answers here the first one
is keeping memories doesn't mean keeping
clutter Amen um so just to your point
Josh we don't have to have memory boxes
to have memories we don't we even don't
have to have a bunch of pictures to have
memories some things do trigger the
memories but really I guess what I'm
trying to lead into is this second pit
the answer which is the more we hold on
to stuff the more we let go of precious
memories what do you always say Josh if
everything is precious then nothing is
precious at all yes am i paraphrasing
that right it's pretty solid yeah if
everything's precious then nothing is
precious and I agree with that if we
treat everything if we hold on the
300,000 items and treat them all as
precious mm-hmm and we're not really
getting value from any of it it becomes
this yeah this the stew of stress and
anxiety and a lot of stuff that's
actually getting in the way of what
you're saying of what is truly precious
to us yeah I mean it's like if we hold
on to zero memories mm-hmm that's I
don't encourage that if we hold on to
300,000 memories I don't encourage that
right and what I like to think is you
know we do this podcast and we write to
help people find that balance between 0
and 300,000 yeah and individual results
may vary
yes all right before we get into our
added value segment and our listener
tips today it looks like we got a bunch
more surprise questions this week Ryan I
can't wait to answer some of these with
you how do you start letting go
that's an important question how do you
start letting go how do you organize all
your passwords I think you Sean about
this because he is the password King so
I've got some answers for you there how
do you get rid of paper clutter with no
scanner how do you get rid of other
people's clutter how do you get kids to
let go of clutter how do you how do you
do with ink how do you deal with things
I owe ya how do you deal with anxiety
from mental clutter you know it's one of
the big things that comes up is we see
all this stuff that we've accumulated
over the years and we just we we want to
hide it because the anxiety just comes
to the forefront almost immediately so I
want to talk to you about that yeah also
to what extent should books be
considered clutter
we're give you the exact number of books
you must own that's right stay tuned
it's three all three of our books no
we're gonna we're gonna talk about books
though because that is one thing that
comes up a lot plus a bunch of more
questions about clutter I'll tell you
what I'm really excited about for this
maximal segment yeah is this article you
picked out for us to go over so pratik
on minimal yes so Josh and I always pick
out some kind of current event to to go
over during the maximal episode and it's
I think it's really important for us to
go over their critiques it's important
for me to critique myself yes like I
don't want to I guess I just don't want
to add more clutter to the world yeah
like I want to actually feel like I'm
doing something that that is meaningful
and I think in order for me to feel that
way I constantly have to question my
motives I have to constantly question my
I don't wanna say my morals but my
values I guess that I need to question
my values so this article is great
because it's a what's the article called
it is called the pitfalls and the
potential of the new minimalism yeah I
mean any by the way it's why one of my
favorite writers in the world Giotto
Latino it's a very it's a very capturing
title and yeah I just cannot wait to go
over this this critique of minimalism
and really unpack what this article is
saying by the way that's the it's a
perfect segue because the that's the
online title the in the
print magazine I think was just called
simple plan's yeah so online they feel
that you have to even these the The New
Yorker which is what what this is in
they feel like they have to get a little
bit click baby there in order to drag
people in but it's a it's a very
well-written article by one of my
favorite writers we're gonna talk about
that and we're gonna talk about a bunch
more about clutter we're gonna do that
on this week's maximal episode you're
currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different maximal
episode on patreon it's called the
minimalist private podcast and if you if
you have a whatever you use I'm gonna
even look at my script here but if you
listen to this podcast and a podcast app
you can also listen to the minimalist
private podcast which is a totally
separate endeavor but it keeps this
podcast 100% advertisement free and it
also gives us the private space we need
to talk about a lot of the things that
that we don't talk about in public it's
like this critiquing article yeah it's
it's a bit of a safe space for us that
our patrons our patreon supporters they
they give us that space to sort of mess
up in real time and talk about things
that we wouldn't necessarily talk about
in front of millions of people will talk
about in front of this small private
podcast audience and you can find that
over at the minimalists com slash
support you can also get a personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app Ryan what else
you got for us this week here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners hi this is Katie from
Philadelphia
I had a tip for the latest podcast with
Courtney harbour and simple clothing
there's a website an app called better
world shopper it ranks companies based
on social responsibility sustainability
environmentalism etc now while I rank
everything they do up a section for
clothes and you can go on the app or the
website and find brands and how they
were based on all these different things
anyway thought that might be helpful for
our listeners who are hoping to buy
sustainable environmentally finally
clothes
hey fellas this is kami in Spokane I
have been thinking about gift-giving as
a love language and I'm totally with you
I don't think it's a real thing I think
it's consumerism driven but I do think
that there's a concept inside of there
that can expand beyond the other
concepts of the other four love
languages that are commonly out there
and I think it's the word that I think
can encompass it because it can go many
different directions is deliberate and I
love somebody who's a deliberate gift
giver because that means they've thought
about me as the recipient not what they
want to give me but they've really
thought about me and that is a powerful
thing to be on the receiving end of
somebody who's really considered what I
want and oftentimes that does bleed into
those other you know quote love
languages but I think it's really
powerful when someone can say you know
what kami I know that you don't want
that box of chocolates I mean you want
to eat them but you're not trying to
grow your ass right now so what I what I
have noticed is that what you love most
is you know X Y Z and it may not cost
any money or maybe it does but it costs
them being deliberate to deliver that
gift and anyway I just think that some
of the best romance can be born out of
that and some of the best friend
connections and even like co-worker
connections of like oh wow they see me
or I see you when you can deliver on
that deliberateness all right so I want
to thank our special guest this week
Ryan Nicodemus thanks for having me man
I really appreciate it you'll find him
at Ryan Nicodemus calm wait I do
actually own that no no just four words
- the minimus I think real quick for
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalists so Ryan you know I teach a
writing class yes and what we do is like
two sometimes three times a year we open
it up for about 48 hours so enrollment
for 48 hours and we limit it to a
hundred students at a time last time it
sold out it sells out most time so if
you're interested in this you can sign
up for the email list over at how to
write better org and we will send you an
email to notice notify you when the
the writing class opens up I want to
help you if you give me four weeks of
your life I'm going to help you write
about our each yeah whether it's blog
posts or books or business emails I can
take these four weeks and show you how
to write better I'll give you the tools
you need you can check out all the
testimonials over there and how to write
better org as well and if you sign up
for that email list you'll also get a
free ebook eleven ways to write better
it's my eleven writing tips my best
writing tips for you which is absolutely
free there's no commitment and I will
warn you this it's not a writing class
that is for everyone necessarily if
you're not willing to put in an hour
worth of work a day for four weeks then
it's probably not for you but I've had
high school students take the class I've
had medical doctors take the class I've
had everyone in between factory workers
and and stay-at-home parents I've had a
lot of people take this class people who
have English as a second language and
the rising tide lifts all boats for me
so if you give me four weeks of your
life an hour a day I will show you how
to write better just check out the
testimonials get your free ebook over at
how to write better org enrollment opens
February 24th and 25th 2020 it's only
open for those 48 hours and only for the
first 100 people that can fit into the
class it's a great class man I remember
taking it when I was living in when we
were living in Phillipsburg yeah Montana
I don't feel like I need to take it
again well you can be one of the 100
right I'll put it on the company credit
card there you go
all right now you can follow the
minimalist on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram at the minimalists if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists com comment
on this episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalist if you're on our show notes
in your inbox sign up for our email list
over at the minimalists comm and you'll
also receive our simple Sunday emails
each week for our added value this week
my favorite song of the year so far Ryan
is this gal named oh seven Oh shake and
she has the song called guilty conscious
which is from her new album modus
vivendi and I want you to check that out
because it is I don't know how to
describe it other than it's like it's
it's the
new pop and it sounds well it sounds so
amazing I think you're gonna enjoy is
the new pop just pop no definitely not
it sort of infuses our MB and hip-hop
and and man it's just such a really
great song so here is oh seven Oh shakes
song guilty conscious and if you leave
here today with just one message we hope
it says love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time and minimus
[Laughter]